so as we know black friday is kind of a
big deal in the retail world
it is the official kickoff to the
holiday shopping season
the busiest time for shoppers and
retailers and of course
it's been met with mixed emotions over
the past few years because of footage we
all see each year of
those infamous stampedes and crazy
frenzied choppers although many frown
upon black friday due to the chaos it
has caused in the past
it's still a big deal when it comes to
sales
in 2019 online sales alone on
thanksgiving day
and black friday hit nearly 12 billion
dollars
according to adobe analytics but with
the pandemic many are wondering whether
the
holiday retail event will look a bit
different this year
it's going to be much more online
centric
rather than in-store centric for safety
reasons
and that changes the impulse equation 25
of all holiday purchases is done on
impulse so if you're not in the stores
looking around and seeing what everybody
else is grabbing or what you might have
bought for a friend and buy for yourself
that's impulse purchase that's going to
be missing this year
so the the department stores are going
to rely
very heavily on utilizing online
utilizing social media utilizing
influencers
and utilizing royalty programs to try to
get consumers to engage
as they spend less time in stores and
visit stores less often so it's a big
deal for
shoppers but it's a bigger deal for
retailers not only is it
the holiday shopping season where
they're pushing all their holiday gift
guides etc their biggest deals their
biggest sales
but it's a great time to clear end of
your inventory
so will 2021 be
more like what 2020 is in part
yes but mostly no consumers are really
looking to go
back to the way things were they want
their kids to go to school normal
they want to be able to work in a normal
environment they want to be able to
socialize
when they want and how they want they
want to be able to shop
again and they want to go out and
socialize again so
look for the shopping part of the
holiday
2021 to be a big part of the social
regathering that's going
to occur